Parodontax
BRIAN: MAJOR DEVELOPMENT IN THE
QUEST FOR THE CORONAVIRUS
VACCINE AS PFIZER ANNOUNCES
THEIR COVID-19 VACCINE MORE THAN
90% EFFECTIVE.
STUNNING NEWS.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
SAYS THERE IS A DOWNSIDE.
>> THE BAD NEWS IS THAT IT’S
ABOUT TWO MONTHS BEFORE JOE
BIDEN TAKES OVER AND THAT MEANS
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
BE IMPLEMENTING A VACCINE PLAN.
THE VACCINE PLAN IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND IT’S PROBABLY THE MOST
AMBITIOUS UNDERTAKING SINCE
COVID BEGAN.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
ROLLING OUT THE VACCINATION PLAN
AND I BELIEVE IT’S FLAWED.
BRIAN: REALLY?
HERE NOW FOX NEWS MEDICAL
CONTRIBUTOR AUTHOR OF THIS GREAT
BOOK "COVID" THE POLITICS OF
FEAR AND THE POWER OF SCIENCE
DR. MARC SIEGEL.
DR. SIEGEL, FIRST OFF, ANDREW
CUOMO DOESESN’T LIKE THE MILITAR
IMPLEMENTING A PLAN THAT’S READY
TO GO AND IT COULD BE MONITORED
IN THEHE SMALLEST HOSPITAL IN TH
BIGGEST CITY?
WHAT’S NOT GOOD ABOUT THIS PLAN
THAT WAS FEATURED ON "60
MINUTES" 48 HOURS AGO?
>> BRIAN, YOU JUST TOOK THE
WORDS OUT OF MY MOUTH.
WE HAVE HER HAD THE BEFORE WHERE
THE DOD THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE, WHICH KNOWS THE WORD
DEPLOYMENT, DON’T THEY?
PARTNERS WITH THE CDC AND THE
McKESSON AND COMPANY ALREADY
SENT VACCINES AROUND THE COUNTRY
MULTIPLE TIMES THE PLAN IS IN
PLACE AND NEVER BEEN DONE THIS
WAY BEFORE.
THEY ARE ALREADY GEARED UP TO
ALREADY SEND OUT 50 TO
100 MILLION DOSES.
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS TALKING ABOUT
UNDERSERVED AREAS BUT THE PLAN
INCLUDES TEMPORARY CLINICS BEING
BUILT IN UNDER SERVED AREAS ON
INDIAN RESERVATIONS IN POOR
NEIGHBORHOODS IN ORDER TO GET
THE VACCINE TO PEOPLE WHO NEED
THE MOST.
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WILL NEED IT,
THE ELDERLY WILL GET IT.
THE POOR MINORITIES WILL GET IT.
ALL IS HE DOING IS SHAKING
CONFIDENCE IN A VACCINE WE HAVE
VERY EXCITING NEWS ABOUT.
OUR BIG PROBLEM IS GOING TO BE
VACCINE COMPLIANCE.
HOW DISTURBING IS THAT FOR HIM
TO BE SHAKING THE CONFIDENCE IN
THIS VACCINE AT EXACTLY THE
WRONG TIME?
BRIAN: WE THINK IT COULD BE
READY.
THEY WANT TO GET THE SHOT GOING,
THEIR WORDS, AT THE END OF THIS
MONTH, BUT THEY NEED TWO SHOTS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
THEN ALL OF THE SUDDEN LATER IN
THE DAY I READ ABOUT MODERNA,
EXCUSE ME, I HAVE GOT ONE, TOO.
WHAT SHOULD WE KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, THAT’S A VERY SIMILAR
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT’S BEEN UNDER THE AUSPICES
OF THE NIH.
THEY ARE LOOKING VERY CLOSELY AT
THE MODERNA VACCINE.
BOTH OF THESE VACCINES USE AGAIN
NET PARTICULAR MATERIAL TO
SIGNAL YOUR CELLS, BRIAN, TO
MAKE THE SPIKE PROTEIN FROM THE
VIRUS.
GUESS WHAT?
WE ARE SEEING ROBUST IMMUNE
RESPONSE WE SAW OVER 90 PERCENT
OF PEOPLE GOT SICK WITH COVID
WERE IN THE LA SEEN BOW GROUP.
THE VACCINE WAS PROTECTIVE.
IT’S NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE AT
THIS RATE OF SPEED.
THIS IS HISTORICAL DAY FOR
SCIENCE.
THE GOVERNOR SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF HIMSELF TO BE ATTACKING THE
VACCINE WHILE WE ARE EXCITED
ABOUT GETTING IT OUT THERE.
BRIAN: BY THE WAY, I WANT TO
MOVE OVER TO BIDEN’S PLAN.
ELI LILLY TO START SHIPPING THE
ANTIVIRUS DRUG IMMEDIATELY AFTER
GETTING EMERGENCY FDA APPROVAL
IN THE SECOND COVID-19 BREAK
THROUGH IN 24 HOURS.
AMAZING JUST A WEEK FROM THE
ELECTION.
OKAY.
I KNOW IT’S A COINCIDENCE.
LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT PRESIDENT-
BIDEN SAID YESTERDAY HE PUT OUT
A PLAN HERE IS THE SKELETON OF
IT RESTORE THE WHITE HOUSE
DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH AND
SECURITY.
REENGAGING WITH THE WHO.
RELAUNCH AGO PACKAGING TRACKING
SYSTEM.
CALLING ALL GOVERNORS TO ENACT
MASK MANDATES AND CALL ON
AUTHORITIES TO REINFORCE ORDERS.
WHAT’S NEW ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, BRIAN, WE ALREADY HAVE
A MASK MANDATE IN OVER 30
STATES.
IN TENNESSEE STUDIED THE MASK
MANDATE RECENTLY AND FOUND WHEN
IT’S DONE IN CONJUNCTION AND
THIS IS THE KEY PART, WITH
DISTANCING AND NO CROWDS, IT
ACTUALLY DECREASES
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
WE KNOW THAT A MASK HELPS.
BUT A MASK IS NOT THE BIG ISSUE.
THE BIG ISSUE IS DISTANCING AND
NOT BEING IN CROWDS.
SO I WAS DISTURBED TO SEAT
CELEBRATORYSEE THECELEBRATORY CR
PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN WAS OUT
THERE AFTER THE ELECTION THERE
WAS CELEBRATORY CROWDS HUDDLING
TOGETHER?
HOW MUCH VIRUS WAS SPREAD THEN.
IF THEY WANT TO SEND A MESSAGE
OF COMPLIANCE.
THE MESSAGE SHOULD BE DON’T
GATHER TO CELEBRATE.
CELEBRATE THE VACCINE BY THE
WAY.
DON’T CELEBRATE VICTORIES.
AND MORE REGULATIONS.
AND MORE MANDATES, BRIAN, ARE
GOING TO LEAD TO NONCOMPLIANCE
NOT MORE COMPLIANCE.
BRIAN: DOCTOR, RIGHT BEFORE I
CAME ON, I CHECKED YOUR BOOK TO
SEE IF THERE WAS AN EXEMPTION IF
NOTRE DAME BEAT CLEMSON CAN YOU
CELEBRATE?
DID YOU NOT HAVE AN EXEMPTION.
I’M SORRY NOTRE DAME, GET TESTED
NOW.
I UNDERSTAND IT’S A BIG WIN BUT
YOU CAN’T RUN ON THE FIELD
WITHOUT MASKS.
>> AND TEST SOMETHING KEY.
TEST SOMETHING KEY, BRIAN.
THAT’S THE THING NOCIALG
EXEMPTION FOR NOTRE DAME.
BRIAN: DON’T LEAVE CAMPUS
WITHOUT GETTING TESTED.